god save me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
yeah that's pete davidson getting
attacked again in kanye west's latest
music video for easy i'm just extremely
happy can you tell by my face it's the
second time we see pete or skeet as
kanye likes to say in the rapper's
visuals within the past week of course
it's all because the 28 year old
comedian is currently dating yay's
estranged wife kim kardashian
god send me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
in the video released wednesday an
animated version of pete gets beat up by
a skinless monkey it's just as bizarre
but not as violent as the first music
video yay dropped last week don't
interrupt
just because it's no love
show the shrug
yeah the first time around fans saw a
claymation kanye kidnapping a claymation
pete burying him alive and decapitating
him
wanna let god in but tonight i guess
i'll let my pride win cousin dre send me
scriptures help me see life better after
criticism online the 44 year old rapper
defended his video by sharing this
message to instagram art is therapy just
like this view art is protected as
freedom of speech art inspires and
simplifies the world art is not a proxy
for any ill or harm
any suggestion otherwise about my art is
false and malintended
just do something for my heart as for
how pete feels about the whole thing
well a source told e.t last week that
the comedian is laughing it off quote he
finds the fact that kanye included a
cartoon version of him in his music
video hysterical he is almost flattered
by it all because it is so ridiculous to
him the source also adds that pete is
not threatened by kanye in any way shape
or form
and get this not only is pete not
bothered the source says he's using the
drama to strengthen his romance
he's using this to grow in more ways
than one including for himself and his
relationship with kim he's turning all
of the negativity into a positive thing
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
[Music]
it's an exciting time for kim who scored
in court last week after her maiden name
was restored and she's now legally
single i'm so excited but when it comes
to her man a source told e.t that the
makeup mogul is upset that he's being
dragged into the drama with kanye
explaining that pete's been nothing but
kind and doesn't deserve it
quote kim is hoping kanye will move on
from publicly mentioning her or pete
god send me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
[Music]